in colombia a 2016 peace deal between
the government
and left-wing farc guerrillas raised
hope that half
of a century of armed conflict would
finally be over but
violence has flared up again recently
fork dissidents
drug trafficking groups and right-wing
paramilitaries are all fighting
to gain control of lucrative markets
like narcotics and illegal mining
now dw's johan ramirez traveled to the
western kalka region
to look into the government's claim that
the security forces have everything
under control
corsain and nubia have run this store
for decades
now only rubber remains a car bomb
exploded
in front of their shop they were both
miraculously unheard
but the piece of colombia was shattered
the attack believed to be carried out by
farc dissidents
casted off a new wave of violence and
uncertainty
[Music]
30 years of commercial struggle
and everything turned to ruins
i don't know what they are buttoned for
because
some do one thing and others to another
and we the people in the middle we are
the worst part
i don't understand the actual target is
probably this building
the mayor's office of the municipality
of korinto
in the southern department of cauca a
week after the incident
the mayor herself cannot understand how
such an outrage
could have happened we are waiting for a
clear response from the public forces as
to how the car
came into the municipality
but the violence in colombia goes much
further
juan manuel camayo coordinator of human
rights in cauca
examines a folder with hundreds of
threats that gorillas paramilitaries and
other irregular groups
have made against the region's
indigenous people over the past
four years
driving through the department of cauca
it's clear that the titan is far from
other
behind a white flag in our window to
show we are unarmed
and not looking for confrontation
in some parts of the road we must wear a
helm and a bulletproof
vest because there is the risk that
irregular groups
will shoot at the car the colombian
government maintains that
security forces carry out patrols to
uphold
peace in the region
the public force has always been here
the cauca commando has eight
thousand men deployed and now an
additional 2000 men
will travel the region to dismantle
these organizations and the message to
them is clear
either they submit or they will be
brought before the public forces
but it will take more than threats the
koreas are still out
there signs indicate which group
controls the territory
despite what the minister says you did
not see
a single soldier on the roads in the day
time
the bats look like no man's land and at
night
in plain sight the mountains included
with the lights of cannabis farms
since recalling the darkest days of
colombia's
civil war
you